okay so what about swiping up on
someone's story yeah is that cheating is
that okay okay is that cheating but you
know the person if you know the point
but as in does he swipe up and he's like
oh have a good workout or is it okay
let's say let's say you you have um an
acquaintance that both of both of you
know okay the guy you and the guy right
and he swipes up on our stories how do
you know if it like is it ever friendly
no is it always not dirty
it is flirty what about guys what do you
think can you repeat that okay so say
say um okay say me and you are dating
right and you and i'm your mutual oh
yeah we're the mutual friend you always
are swiping up on her story
but like we both know right
is it ever friendly if i'm always doing
it there's there's an under there's
probably an underlying exactly yeah
like i said if he's just like oh do you
know when or was the movie good was this
good like what that's that's fine we're
like reacting all the time
yeah
[Music]